[Music]
hello and welcome to Ana's trailer
commentaries the show where you just
watch the oz trailer and you're still
bored so you watch this one we're going
to talk about what you just watch
hopefully and then stick around the end
a little few outtakes
if you cut jokes few things didn't make
it in I'm Spencer Jake Gilbert that's
Joestar that's Demerol okay The
Incredibles we watched it we watched it
we made an honest trailer because that's
what we do here and yet not much to say
about this movie as you may not have may
have noticed it's a good movie we all
enjoy it see you next week
alright guys seriously like watching
girls I was stumped after watch this
first time like this is good I like it
it's really solid movie it's it's the
paradox of working on honest trailers a
lot of times which is that the movies
that the people want the most are often
also the movies that are good which
makes them hard to do honest trailers on
but also do even heart well I feel like
The Godfather is easier than Pixar
movies Pixar movies to me are the
ultimate in difficulty because even the
nitpicks are excused by the fact that
it's animated the things that don't kind
of continuity errors things that don't
make sense you're in a fantasy world
already so it seems stupid to just gang
up on it for that oh that guy can fly
just yes you can right yeah it's a it's
a made-up kid's world and yeah and the
fact that like they're all they're
almost like parables and they're just
these Pixar movies are just stories told
in service of a message or a femoral and
stuff like that so they're just so what
do you guys did like the power of
friendship big family exactly this one
doesn't even have that old crutch of how
does it even work which if you look back
at other Pixar movies today with Toy
Story and with cars and with inside out
because at least it had a premise where
we could go at least with like but how
would that really work yeah because you
know look like yeah did the toy
but it's something to do and this one
even was just like this would even still
is just like okay yeah yeah so yeah I
hope people enjoyed the trailer or maybe
they just watched it because they loved
the movie I had forgotten how good it is
like cuz I haven't watched it I don't
think since it probably came out on DVD
and I remember just remember I remember
the talking point of this is the best
Fantastic Four movie ever made
but I think even after now we've seen
246 MCU films a lot of juicy movies I
still think this is arguably arguably
top 5 top 3 I mean it really gets to the
heart and by being just kind of this
kind of tasty
goulash of all other superhero worlds
and also of like it seems like British
mods by culture James Bond sixties yeah
yeah yeah gets to pick and choose the
best of all and and get at the core of
superhero entertainment which is that
some people are just better than us and
we need to just get in line and accept
that you tell me that every day it's
still hard to some people are just born
with special abilities and they are held
back by bureaucracy I don't follow you
check out podcast Spencer shrugged I'm
16 and it's the first book I ever read
yeah anyways why don't we talk about the
actual movie we are honest trailer for
The Incredibles
[Music]
if you like well-written animated films
with hard humour and great action
actually scratch that if you are
currently or have ever been alive then
you probably love The Incredibles
pause Dino need contrarians who are like
worst movie ever I'm sure they're out
there I'm sure they're out there I'm
sure there's some are you a contrarian
chime in the comments below
wonder if any notable critics gave
incredible I'm gonna well we're doing
this I'm gonna look at the reviews and
see if there who went wrong oh whatever
any crazy guy that always goes
contrarian didn't like it yeah he's got
some some interesting thoughts on things
psyche we keep going I'm just gonna look
this up well experience a film that's
got a little bit of everything from
Silver Age comic book heroes to a dark
snapshot of a dying marriage slick retro
James Bond style to a portrait of a
midlife crisis the warm glow of familial
love to the soul-crushing modern-day
workplace once again you'll pay Pixar to
yank your heart around like an emotional
yo-yo pause I think that mr. mrs.
incredible have a terrible marriage and
it was ever good if you follow unless
it's obviously off-camera who knows but
when they meet they're like sparring
it's kind of like a war words they are
bickering in every single scene except
for the ones where he's lying to her
including him the alter including at the
altar there they're like working out the
details like this is gonna work you've
got it like you need to have that
conversation before yeah you can't have
that conversation you can't pop that
there after you've popped the other
question they are always at each other's
throats it's just a bad mix except like
they're both super well it's um thanks
for asking thanks for asking I think you
know at the beginning it's a it's a cool
look at because at the beginning it's
definitely like flirty honeymoon phase
where there's still bat Batman and
Catwoman look at each other on rooftops
and we don't see the like
any of the in-between we just see hey
it's the fun sexy beginning and then
it's the fun sexy marriage like it goes
BAM right pay out there well well yeah
yeah and then we go straight to worst
possible timeline
we're like full midlife crisis like I
just want to start punching people again
and yeah so we don't see any of any of
that middle but I don't I think it's
cool story telling that they that they
get to skip by not having like an IP
they're attached to by being able to
start their story in the middle if that
makes sense like there's not it
Incredibles where it's like oh they're
getting together and that got married
because who cares like it's more
interesting that they they get to start
their Fantastic Four we've been the
Fantastic Four for 15 years and it's
really started to put some strain on sue
and Reed's relationship well I think
that Fantastic Four gets thrown around a
lot but this has way more Watchmen per
host it does it's very much like world
where Superman outlawed they're all
miserable it's it's grounding
superheroes down in like real life
issues yeah
they kill a lot of people they they
really do the murder the murder you
could tell this his early pics are
because the murder quotient in this
movie is extremely why do they add to
their body count they blunt the edges
way more than they had in this like I
think people still bite it but not
necessarily like in the way of like
those dudes and the flying saucers going
like yeah I was there's no ambiguity
there they're just done to rewatch i
stopped and i was like where are the
parachutes like where is the last second
GI Joe like boom I know they're working
for a evil killer robot company but you
know job what did he contribute to this
factor yeah of things sorry I found a
few things that I'm gonna bring up later
okay in the meantime let's keep watching
beat the parse an incredibly
dysfunctional family violet is neglected
- is hurting people for fun Bob is
sneaking around behind his wife's back
and Helens in denial about his obvious
lies sweetie
they've got more issues than a comic
book shop and the only way to resolve
them is to put on spandex and beat the
crap out of some robots together and
reward government advance superheroes
for fairly obvious reasons you knock
down a building now Bob will have to
adjust and not being able to punch
people for a living until he leaves in
an opportunity to work for a killer
robot company with a volcano lair dude
you were a hero for like decades you
didn't see any red flags here I'm
starting to think this guy just wants to
hurt people with no consequences hey
heroes don't do that unless you're
Batman Batman totally does that cower
before the best super villains of all
time syndrome a perfect prediction of
today's entitled fan culture he's a nerd
who loves something so much then when it
didn't live up to his expectations
you're not affiliated with me he
declared war on it
all right so the comments were probably
talked about this month the two the
three of us are talking today about the
situational potential irony of this
because we record these before the
trailer goes public
our referring to a fan people calling
declaring war on something that they
used to love how this might blow back on
us for calling out fans for calling out
things that they still love oh we're
going like four levels deep here yeah
we're deep in the dream yeah but we're
praising syndrome we're praising the
movie for creating syndrome for calling
out entitled fan culture which reflects
today's entitled fan culture yes we're
calling out who will then call out us in
an entitled fan way wish I had a coin to
spit I know right am I awake or am i
what we're saying is that is that
syndrome would be very active on many
internet sites oh you were everyone's
become syndrome I mean the world is
syndrome now yes yes he's I think it's
great that it's Jason
- because it's like darkest timeline
Brodie for a mall rats yeah yeah he's
the greatest comic book nerd who you
have to love them and is now just
resentful yeah I think they kind of
nailed it
yeah it was it is it is a weird cuz it's
been a while since I revisited this
movie seeing syndrome and then just kind
of the thing just like I love you and
he's like no please not now
and the way that he kind of says okay
well then if everyone's super then
you're not anymore and then just the
whole way of just this extravagant
revenge scheme it's like this is kind of
prescient yeah it was I think later
happening unrealistically they made
syndrome good at doing things which I
think in real life is more like he would
have stayed just ranting against yes
there was no internet yes who else did
this not nearly as well was a killed
something I'm in three grave monger
killed Kelly Killian Kulu Gilead yeah
was the snubbed snubbed guy at the
beginning of that one that he was went
on to invent the Mandarin I guess a lot
of superhero movies have taken like
pieces from Incredibles like first class
took the setting and like sort of visual
style they to be fair the sixties
actually happened and the a 10 we're in
the sixties yes but just I could see
someone being like hey Pixar made that
look really cool do the thing yeah a lot
of movies have snagged from Pixar I
think this one was more of a Noma I
think yeah I would say this stole the
other way around yeah something to say
let's keep I said I said a sentence I
declare war on you jus
yeah signing a change.org petition
shoujo he was wrong in that anecdote yes
a lot of people in the comments that
will sign we the undersigned demand that
screen junkies acknowledge the shaky
ground on the metaphor that Joestar
brought up his trailer commentaries from
Incredibles with them before which just
says that they took the other thing from
The Incredibles today the other way
around we had enough of these sloppy
analogies and we will boy
caught honest trailers until the Dalek
company acknowledges the sloppy
workmanship of though the idea not Canon
that understand you w WQ t yr l
analogous ran johnson brett iron iron
rayon and rayon johnson reloj letting me
buy rocket boots I'll sell my invention
so that everyone can be superheroes well
that's just great now how am I supposed
to become a hero
toxic waste covered reptiles aren't
cheap you know enjoy the best Fantastic
Four movie never made that fixes on the
foss from those awful awful fills having
it's for Heroes feel like a real family
not treating their powers like a joke
and making it so mr. fantastic is
married to the thing which is way hotter
I mean better I mean damn it they're
just both so thick so just look there's
another when we were looking at dumb
change.org petitions one was a petition
to be able to marry cartoon characters
take change.org let me marry a cartoon
so how many so they wanna marry I don't
remember and I don't remember who
exactly they want to marry I think it
was just like you know legalizing the
idea of in fact if that one went through
who would you marry the Space Jam yeah I
can see that you guys would do really
well together got a lot of attitude
don't wonder if the person that invented
change.org is like oh my god what if I
let me do Daffy Duck when he dresses up
like a girl bunny or whatever
Spencer seasoned it kid plank so cheer
up Logan and turn that frown upside down
Rorschach cuz we're printables proof you
don't have to be r-rated to be a violent
angry movie with the super high body
count attempted suicide heroes
threatening to murder innocent people
it'll be
like breaking a toothpick grown-man
shooting at little kids and little kids
killing grown men you wonder with me
Brad bird fly into a homicidal rage
between the Iron Giant in this movie
money money money money money
story Punk he'll stretch us across honey
wow you're turning violet violet the
Epcot Center grown-up Stewie do you find
something comical about my hair it's not
driving my automobile this is fantastic
40 so then okay Brad that Edna goes on
nuts were those her designs that got all
those heroes killed before she learned
her lesson because whoo that's dark
poor it that's for super dead
superheroes on her costume design mmm
yep mm-hmm
think you would have learned if you're
doing it together maybe three did she
design syndromes costume had a cape
right did he well she wouldn't work for
syndrome huh we don't know much about
her man yeah she does seem into like she
did make a super suit for a baby
yeah that's pretty weird just in case
your baby we put your baby in a
life-threatening situation yeah I hear
the baby is the best part of the sequel
he is indeed okay that's nice to hear I
was worried that he would be like a
Great Gazoo kind of like situation yeah
not in a cheap way like no the baby's
the best part like no it's actually the
best part a good movie and the baby is
the best part of cool
cereza there you go Jack Jack Jack Jack
let's watch some deleted scenes yes
they've got more issues than a comic
book shop and the only way to resolve
him is to put on spandex and beat the
crap out of some robots together
and these kids get off easy my dad put
me in Spanish and beat me with a rumba
pasta Wow yeah the readings a little
muddled and also it's just so weird
but it adds to the mythos of Johnson
epic voice guys miss I guess that was
after he stumbled into the his parents
Red Room yeah Red Room of pain and what
happened immediately after that yeah
actually that does fit the mythos cuz
his dad put made him wear spandex and
then beat him with a Roomba yeah it's
too dark and weird
what is that cannon if it was deleted is
it cannon not cannon no dude you can't
okay but in my head I'm starting to
think this guy just wants to hurt people
with no consequences yeesh just quit and
pooping the water cooler like a normal
person you maniac story yeah another
epic voice guy window into his thought
processes I'm so hard you have to you
have to take the time off without
spilling anything yeah but what I always
turned it over and that hole is not with
depending on a big damn big this thing
called Sparkletts bottle but wouldn't it
just go down into the reservoir and then
no one would know is it a is it a subtle
well maybe what started us eat it out
you'd poop in it then you'd fill it back
up uh-huh and it'd be like a fish bowl
like that like called a brown fish
strong triangle man triangle man you
think just because a guy reads comics he
can't start shouldn't have named him -
if you didn't want him to go fast mr.
Chuck perks of being a wallflower
shrinking violet not an invisible girl
not yet an Invisible Woman and spin the
iron giant Watchmen for kids and that's
all that's it yeah
do we want to hear the people that that
panned yeah twelve of them
Jimmy Oh from film snob Oh Jimmy I'm
film snob and unfortunate used to Pixar
magic to tell a tired story at a typical
world which back in 2004 I think it's a
little it's a little harsh I feel like
he
that's a retro review when I go back
Thomas de lappa from Boulder Weekly said
it's a cyber : of eye candy that's also
loaded with empty calories so not
impressed Wow
Jeremy Heilmann from movie martyr calm
it's already I like film snob and movie
martyr about 15 out of a hundred this
show since it's too much a crowd-pleaser
to be critical of the violent payoff
that it delivers it's tough not to take
its apparent message seriously that was
word soup right there right Sean
O'Connell from Eclipse magazine b- so
this is this is borderline that's
probably not the most original thought
that's ever crossed their collective
minds so standard-issue superhero
adventure so yeah I don't exist yet
that's true there was all four superhero
movies yeah bird and the Pixar whizzes
do what they do excellently you just
wish they were doing something else
that's eleanor Ringgold cater from the
Atlanta journal-constitution
Helen or wrinkle wrinkle hello Ringo
now this is when Frederick and Mary and
Bruce sought from spirituality and
practice The Incredibles promotes a new
moral slogan for our time so the family
that fights evildoers together stays
together two out of five that was just a
description yeah it was I want to do a
show where we just read reviews from
them yeah from spirituality and practice
I was gonna say a show where we review
spirituality and practice oh maybe
that's maybe that's I do a seance and
The Village Voice says overcrowded
Hollywood eardrum bashing metal
crunching action sludge strangely enough
the the most this shouldn't be
surprising the most heartless the
audience score which is only 75%
one-fourth of the audience that voted
apparently not fans of the incredible
surprised okay yeah yeah be to 75% I
mean we choke right at the beginning I
maybe it's just the circle we hang out
in but I feel like this is universally
level I mean a bubble not a monk oh no
we're in a liberal bubble oh boy
incredible
anyways so we have we have nothing to
say about movie so we just read reviews
yeah I am surprised yeah so there you go
well let's get back to our latte-sipping
Prius driving bubble and hope you'll
join us here next week when we talk
about what are we doing
Oh Oh third third time is not the charm
not at all
no no no but you'll find out if you
stick around next week right here on
honest trailer commentaries
[Music]
you